this island is disappearing quickly both
federal and state government
in january 2016 the residents of il
dejean charles
in the united states were thrust into
the spotlight
less than 10 percent of the land that
stood six decades ago remains today
the united states government allocated
48 million dollars
to move the community in louisiana to
higher ground
the first federal assistance of its kind
the new town dubbed the new isle is
located 40 miles northwest of the
community
on a former sugar cane farm although
there will be fishing ponds
it'll be different than the crabbing and
fishing possible off the gulf of mexico
people with roots in il dijon charles
are descendants of native people
forced to settle on the land in the
1830s
some worry that the cultural heritage of
their community will be
lost by moving and have chosen to stay
behind
five and a half years after the initial
announcement residents who have decided
to relocate
have seen a glimpse of where their new
homes will be built
across the world similar difficult
decisions
will have to be made researchers like
marjolin hasnot
believe the key to successful relocation
is breaking down the decision
into manageable steps we need to unravel
this big decision what does it take over
time
what could be no regret measures to do
now
and maybe we don't have to make the full
decision yet
because there is also uncertainty about
the amount and rate of sea level rise
but at least we keep the options open
managed retreat proactively moving
people away from risk
has become a prominent area of research
it starts with identifying
what are the risks now but also in the
future
what could be potential options to to
adapt
and then the next step could be to
identify the
effectiveness of these options and the
costs and benefits and then
sequence them once you've done that you
can
evaluate these adaptation pathways and
then identify
okay what are the near-term actions to
prepare
and possible long-term options to adapt
if needed
and that can be implemented as the
future unfolds
near-term actions could include
protective measures that buy time before
relocation
but fortifying coastlines with
infrastructure such as sea walls
is not always the answer we cannot
protect everything so ah because that's
very costly and it goes
quite long so where do you want to
protect
and where do you make the difficult
choice to retreat
there are places in the world like the
netherlands but also in japan
where there are already these high sea
walls
to some extent they can be built but on
the other hand we get more disconnected
from the sea and the sea also provides
us
goods like livelihoods and recreation
and tourism in bangladesh we can't do
that
we do have embankments we have boulders
we have places
where we can build something of a sea
wall to protect some
infrastructure but we can't do it
everywhere and we certainly can't do it
for agricultural land anymore
and as a result some people are not
being able to continue to live there
they're losing their livelihood huck's
work emphasizes the importance of
building economic opportunity
into relocation plans so one of the
biggest challenges we have is everybody
moves to dhaka in bangladesh so anybody
being displaced from any other part of
the country ends up in islam in dhaka
city
and dhaka can't absorb the projected
numbers of
up to 10 million climate refugees or
migrants coming in
over the next decade or so so we are
exploring different ways in which we can
make these
other towns there are about 20 of them
with a population of about
half a million to a million each that we
can help them absorb another half a
million to a million each over the next
decade and enabling them to
settle there enabling them to become
part of the community
enabling them to get economic
opportunities these are things that we
work on in terms of local adaptation
throughout the relocation process the
people being displaced
must play a role in decision making i've
been doing a lot of work on
what we call bottom-up consultation
making sure the voices of the vulnerable
are taken into account
making them agents of change
less economically developed countries
will be disproportionately
impacted by climate change but early
decision making
can help prevent catastrophes in the
future
sea level will rise in the future and no
matter what we do it will rise
for decades and even in the next
centuries
and that many decisions that we take now
have a very long legacy
into the future
you